just tell us a little bit about what
what happened down in mar-a-lago last
night um president trump has called it a
raid was it such
i don't think that's the right word jane
it's a court authorized search warrant
that means the department of justice the
fbi
went to a
federal judge a neutral and detached
magistrate and swore out a warrant which
demonstrated probable cause for two
things one that a crime had been
committed and second that they would
find evidence of that crime at the place
they wanted to search in this case
mr trump's florida home so i think a
raid is a
an inaccurate and unfortunate term it's
a court authorized search warrant they
were lawfully present because a judge
said they could be there
so what were they looking for
right so we don't entirely know because
the search warrant is under seal it will
be unsealed at some point but right now
it remains sealed and that's standard
protocol
they're looking for evidence of a crime
now which crime and what evidence that
will all be specified in the warrant and
when we see it we'll know more about
that piece of it
so that actual looking for evidence of a
crime is quite interesting isn't it so
it's it's not simply the case as far as
you're aware that they're just looking
to recover documents they're they are
actually looking for evidence of a crime
or is it the case that the fact that the
documents that should be in the national
archives are there is a crime in itself
well the documents in and of themselves
could be the evidence of the crime but
to get a search warrant under u.s law
and by the way our fourth amendment uh
comes from english common law i mean the
antecedents were the objections of the
colonists to english authorities using
what were called general writs of
assistance to do searches at any home at
any time and so our fourth amendment
narrowed that right it's much like
english common law now you have to have
a specific crime and you have to tell
the judge who is in a different branch
of our government so two branches of our
government are involved in a search
warrant you have to tell the judge what
it is you're looking for that would be a
violation of u.s federal law so it is
rather specific we just don't have the
specifics yet jane
but but we we are assuming that that
it's documentation that relates to his
time as president and that that
documents
those should have been lodged in the
national archives why why is it
important why is there this precedent
that these kind of notes or bits of
paper that the president uses go to this
special place
well two things first we have something
called the presidential records act
which requires presidents to turn over
their
official papers to our national archives
but second and i think more important
here and this goes to your very good
question
if the documents are classified at a
high level
and disclosure of them could do grave
damage to u.s national security
interests well then it's a crime
actually there are a suite of crimes
related to mishandling or improperly
retaining or in the worst case
transmitting classified information so
that's the crime at least the potential
crime you can't mishandle retain
transmit
classified information as a former
president mr trump no longer has the
authority to classify or declassify
information nor can he retain it and so
um that could be the underlying reason
why the fbi went to a judge and asked
for the search warrant
and has this ever happened before he
says that it's been unprecedented that a
president has been treated like this
well
to my knowledge unprecedented that uh
the home of a former president would be
searched
but very much precedent for the notion
that if you break the law regardless of
who you are
then you suffer the consequences right
now the consequence is a search warrant
again
authorized by a federal judge and
lawfully executed whether or not he's
charged i have absolutely no idea jane
but there was a determination made by a
federal judge that there was probable
cause to believe a crime would become
had been committed and that you would
find evidence at his home so in that
sense
this is what happens when people commit
crimes what is unprecedented is it
happens to be a potential crime by a
former president of the united states
and just a final thought chuck when the
fbi go in on these operations to recover
stuff is it is anything off limits we
we've had president trump's son saying
that that that this safe was i think it
is broken into but i mean
when they get a warrant for to search a
property can they pretty much go
anywhere
yeah so that's a great question jane let
me explain it this way if you had a
search warrant for my home because
you're looking for a stolen car you
couldn't look in my refrigerator and you
couldn't look in my safe it wouldn't
make sense that you'd find a stolen car
in one of those places but if you have a
search warrant for documents a safe is a
very logical place and so when the fbi
has a search warrant that includes
things that could be in a safe then they
lawfully have access to the safe ideally
the homeowner gives the combination to
the safe and the fbi doesn't have to
break into it but if they did break into
it it's because they had lawful access
to it and so i think mr trump's son is
making um a bit of a fuss here uh and i
understand why they might be upset but
this is pursuant to law it was properly
authorized and it seems to me properly
executed
chuck rosenberg former u.s attorney and
former senior fbi official thank you
very much
thank you